the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
after a nearly four hour violent
standoff inside the nation's capital
congress reconvened wednesday night to
certify democratic president-elect joe
biden's electoral college win in the
november election
we know that we would be part of history
in a positive way today
every four years when we
demonstrate again the peaceful transfer
of power
from one president to the next and
despite the shameful
actions of today we still
will do so i've traveled the world with
joe i hoped he lost i prayed he would
lose
he won he's the legitimate
president of the united states
earlier that day around 2pm pro-trump
rioters jumped barricades and smashed
windows
quickly overwhelming police and storming
the capitol building
it will stand in recess until the call
of the chair
will foster protesters are in the
building thank you
[Music]
lawmakers were interrupted evacuated and
ordered to lock themselves in their
offices
as hundreds of riders entered the
building
[Applause]
some could be seen throughout the
building waving trump and american flags
and cheering from the balconies as
thousands of other people surrounded the
building
one woman was shot by capitol police and
three others died in the unrest
about an hour before the violence broke
out president trump spoke to supporters
at a rally
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol we're
going to try and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong ones don't need any of our
help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
at trump's speech in the morning it
seemed like
a fairly contained fairly organized
event
[Applause]
this way but at the capitol things
really changed
and it suddenly felt out of control and
you weren't sure which way things were
going where the energy in the crowd was
was going president-elect joe biden
condemned the violence and called for
the certification of the electoral
college results to continue
this is not dissent it's disorder
it's chaos it borders on sedition
and it must end now
i call on this mob to pull back and
allow the work of democracy to go
forward
shortly after he spoke president trump
posted a recorded video on social media
it was a landslide election and everyone
knows it
especially the other side but you have
to go home now
we have to have peace we have to have
law and order
the video was later removed by twitter
youtube and facebook for violating their
policies
facebook's vp of integrity said this is
an emergency situation
and we removed it because on balance we
believe it contributes to
rather than diminishes the risk of
ongoing violence
trump later tweeted these are the things
and events that happen when a sacred
landslide election victory is so
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away
from great patriots who have been badly
and unfairly treated for so long
go home with love and in peace remember
this day forever
following that tweet twitter locked the
president's account for 12 hours
and warned that further violations could
lead it to permanently suspend the
president's account
[Music]
the violence the capital prompted
district of columbia mayor muriel bowser
to declare a 6pm curfew
and more than a thousand dc national
guard troops were called in to help
maintain order
one thousand new york national guard
members will also be deployed
some white house staffers resigned
following the events of the day
including a top national security
council official and the first lady's
chief of staff and press secretary
the scenes of violence drew condemnation
from leaders around the world
what happened today in washington dc is
not america
definitely we believe
in the strength of our democracies
as rioters broke into the capital around
2pm wednesday
lawmakers had just begun discussing a
challenge by some republican lawmakers
to the vote tally in arizona
a debate that exposed a deep divide
within the party what does it
say to the nearly half the country that
believes this election was rigged
if we vote not even to consider the
claims
of illegality and fraud in this election
and i believe there's a better way this
election were overturned
by mere allegations from the losing side
our democracy would enter a death spiral
we'd never see the whole nation except
an election again when congress
reconvene
the day of unrest prompted some
republicans to reconsider their decision
to object to the certification of votes
following the events of today it appears
that some senators have withdrawn their
objection
when i arrived in washington this
morning i fully intended to object to
the certification of the electoral votes
however the events that have transpired
today have forced me to reconsider
and i cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
of these electors but some republicans
stood by their decision to object
for those who have concerns about the
integrity of our elections those who
have concerns about what happened in
november
this is the appropriate means this is
the lawful
place where those objections and
concerns
should be heard not through violence not
by appealing from ballots to bullets
but here in this lawful process after
congress certified biden's victory
president trump issued a statement
committing to an orderly transition of
power on january 20th
despite disagreeing with the outcome